- It's like we're trapped in some like,
sex dungeon and we're just
opening up different doors.
(dramatic music)
ChatRoulette is a website where you go
and you have video conferences
with total strangers.
- I was always interested
in going on ChatRoulette,
but I was a little too nervous.
- There's gonna be a lot
of nudity, I feel (laughs)
- Bring it on.
- I think ChatRoulette is just
people looking for friends.
- It's already hard enough to be a woman
and like, you're randomly
get an unsolicited dick pic.
I don't need to just like,
randomly be on a site like,
"Let's see what's gonna happen!"
- I expect some dick.
- My mother's probably
gonna watch this and like...
- What if we see your mom on ChatRoulette?
- This looks like the 90's.
Like, this looks like AOL AIM.
- It's so rudimentary.
- It's so antiquated.
- Rules!
- What's number one?
Broadcasting or offering
nudity is not allowed.
- Oh, it's someone in Argentina.
- Oh, keep...
- Pass.
- [Voiceover] Okay, he's cute, Hi.
- Wait, did they just like keep on
- Yeah, they're hittin' next.
- Oh, that's bullshit.
- You're just dancin' with
a guy in Russia right now.
See?
- Oh my God.
- Shirtless dude.
Another shirtless dude.
- Alright he's typing.
"Are you lesbians?"
(simultaneously) No we're not.
- Here's a picture of
George Washington, okay.
- He's actually really funny (laughs)
- Hi.
- "Help me cum please
I suck dick for boobs."
(laughs) What?
- This is my Batman joker voice.
- Oh joker voice.
- I'm so serious.
- Oh
- Nice.
He's wearing a gangnam style t-shirt.
- Oh!
- Oh shit!
Oh my God, he's packing enough.
We saw a flacid penis,
it was about yeah-long.
just chillin' on this guy.
- I like your beard.
- Are you being flirty?
- I'm just, you know (laughs)
- Have you ever heard of BuzzFeed?
- It is my favorite channel on YouTube.
- Is it really?
- No, I don't want to
have phone sex with you.
What am I, 12?
- [Voiceover] Oh, she's not wearing pants.
- Ohh.
- Okay, okay. okay.
- Really sweet, innocent looking girl,
she was very close to the camera,
and then she moved back and a guy had
an erect penis and she started sucking it.
Right in front of us.
- You're a teacher?
What do you teach?
- I teach science.
- Oh nice.
- Word.
- Oh, it's a girl!
- Hello!
- Hi!
Please don't show us your dick.
- What brings you to ChatRoulette?
- To practice my English, I think.
- Oh nice, it's very good.
- That's great.
- Do you know the Try Guys?
- Yeah, we know the Try Guys.
- They are my favorite.
- The Try Guys are your favorite?
- Yay!
- We met someone that
wants to change the world.
- That's fantastic.
What a wonderful ending.
We got to actually make a friend in Spain.
- We didn't find anyone that was nice,
and it just was like, it
just felt empty and isolated.
- Yeah.
- And alone.
- It's a very dark place of the Internet.
- It felt like fishing.
You know, like once you caught one,
I didn't want to offend him,
I didn't want to scare him off.
I wanted to have a conversation.
- I kinda, you know, gained
trust and faith in ChatRoulette.
- What could be very
deep, is very shallow.
- Yes, there is that one
percent chance you're gonna
find someone awesome, like we found David.
But then there's 99 percent
chance that you're just gonna
be completely scarred for
the rest of your life.
- Just dicks everywhere,
like just dicks assaulting your face.
Just dicks in your dreams.
Just dick nightmare.
Dick surprise.
- It's here! It's here!
(girls simultaneously) - It's here!
- It's here.
- It's here. Get it.
- Get it.
- There, I think I got it. Get it.
- Yeah, you got it.
- It's here.